20 years ago a group of scientists
decided to find out if there were other
paradises out there so-called exoplanets
orbiting the stars that light up our
night
sky just in the last decade we've had
this explosion in the discovery of these
exoplanets which has revolutionized the
whole field of
[Music]
astronomy the early days of exoplanet
hunting turned up enormous Jupiter sized
planets by the
boatload these hot gassy Giants proved
easy to find but hostile to Life as we
know it now though new telescopes and
technologies have allowed astronomers to
Target smaller planets earth-sized ones
and the stunning results have
transformed the way we see our place in
the
universe we we now know something
precious that our planet Earth is not
unique it's not even rare there are tons
hordes flocks if you will of other
earthlike planets out there fluttering
around the other stars some Stars
probably have multiple Earths orbiting
them that's how common earthlike planets
[Music]
are we owe this exoplanet explosion to a
Space Telescope called
Kepler the Kepler space telescope is an
observatory in space that is staring at
one spot in the sky it's looking at
roughly
150,000 stars and it's looking for The
Telltale sign of planets orbiting those
stars then every time the planet passes
in front of the star it'll block a
little bit of that star light and if you
plot the amount of light you get from
the Star it drops and then goes back up
as the planet
passes
in Just 4 years scientists have detected
over a thousand exoplanets just from
their
Shadows it can't tell that the shadow is
made by a giant gassy Planet hostile to
life or a potentially habitable
earthlike
planet what we're measuring when a when
a planet passes in front of its host
star is what is the area of the
planet relative to the area of the star
that it's passing in front of it's a
it's a ratio
basically big Jupiter sized planets
Crossing giant Stars fool Kepler because
they block the same fraction of light as
earth-sized planets Crossing smaller
stars to prove a planet is Earth sized
you need to measure the size of its Star
first using the world's biggest
telescope Scopes but it's timec
consuming expensive and creates a huge
exoplanet
backlog but astronomer Kavon stassen has
come up with an ingenious shortcut by
turning the raw Kepler data into
sound what the Kepler Telescope directly
measures and the data that we use is the
small changes in brightness that a star
produces due to the flickering uh AR in
from the boiling and roiling motions of
gas at its surface what we can do then
is take that light flickering data and
transform it in a Sound Studio for
example into audio frequencies and so
then we can represent with sound what
we're actually detecting with
light the bigger the star is the more
its surface boils with
activity making big stars flicker more
powerfully converted to sound this
boiling becomes a deafening
hiss well let's listen to some Stars
okay can we hear the Red Giant star
please I'm going to bring up the volume
here this is a very large star very low
density and so that large amount of hiss
is the result of vigorous boiling and
churning at the surface of this large
red giant
star can we get the dwarf star
please on smaller Stars sunspots
dominate the sound profile creating a
low frequency
drone actually sounds like a series of
clicks beneath the clicks lies the faint
hiss needed to size the star
underneath it at a very low level is a
little bit of
hiss that little bit
of is actually the light flickering that
we're interested
in by accurately measuring the level of
this background hiss Kayon can work out
the size of the star in this case it's
around the same size as our star the
sun kon's work could be the Breakthrough
exoplanet Hunters have been hoping for
it's cheap the results are practically
instantaneous and once you know the size
of the star it's Child's Play to work
out the size of the planet casting
Shadows over
it it it feels like a very privileged
time to be a scientist to be an
astronomer uh working in this area and
contributing to the hunt for the next
Earth here we are actually discovering
ing these worlds by the hundreds and now
on the cusp of being able to identify
the next
Earth astronomers suspect there could be
tens of billions of rocky earthlike
planets in the Milky Way places where
perhaps life has gotten a
foothold but Life as we know it requires
water how can scientists possibly find
this miracle substance on planets light
years
[Music]
away water divides Our Living
World those with it Prosper those
without
suffer remarkable ably the water we
drink today contains the same atoms as
the water dinosaurs drank 100 million
years ago it's the same water that
formed clouds over the early Earth 4
billion years ago and every organism
that has ever existed on Earth has used
this single ration of water as the
biochemical Powerhouse that keeps it
alive on Earth all all life requires
liquid water to grow and reproduce it's
the common ecological requirement for
Life liquid water is just so good for
getting Evolution going molecules can
dissolve in the water actually interact
with each other form more complex chains
it does it with charge there's positive
charges and negative charges separated
between the hydrogen and the oxygen in
H2O those charges break apart the
hydrocarbons the carbon-based molecules
that persist everywhere in nature now
that's very rare hardly any other
liquids do that so liquid water is a
natural starting place when you look out
into the universe and say what planets
could possibly have
life to understand how much liquid water
is out there astronomers must first
calculate how common water is in all its
forms amazingly they find it everywhere
they look water is incredibly common in
its gaseous form we see water vapor
filling the space between the Stars we
see it in clouds of material that are
actually forming new stars and planets
right
now since water is a fundamental
building block of stars and planets then
exoplanet worlds must surely have it in
abundance but if you're looking for life
you need to find liquid water and plenty
of it it to find it astronomers take
their cue from a fairy
tale everybody knows the famous story of
Goldilocks and the Three Bears and the
the cup of porridge where one was too
hot one was too cold one was just right
when it comes to cooking up life like a
porridge you need to have an environment
that's not too hot not too cold just
right and traditionally we look for that
at a certain distance around a
star at first astronomers based this
magical distance known as the Goldilocks
zone on the Earth's orbit around the Sun
but as they've found more and more
exoplanets they've had to re-evaluate
the boundaries for liquid water there
isn't a single distance it depends on
the brightness of your parent star a dim
star you need to be
closer a hot star very bright you need
to be farther
away scientists have calculated how how
many rocky planets May lie within the
goldilock zone of the Stars it comes out
to over 30 billion potentially watery
worlds even more remarkably recent
discoveries have shown us it's not just
planets that can bask in the warmth of
the goldilock Zone there may be moons
painted blue with oceans
too